pour moi ya vraiment un aller retour
entre l'expérimentation artistique où
parfois on va on va on va être confronté
avec des choses qu'on n'aurait pas pu
rencontrer si on était resté dans la
pensée ou ses intérêts c'est juste d'or
d'une réflexion avec un bang ses pensées
ses réflexions noé soulier les pauses
les traduit par le mouvement par la
danse
ce jeune chorégraphe passé par le
conservatoire national de paris est
aussi un passionné de philosophie
je pense que ce qui m'interroge vraiment
c'est c'est l'expérience finalement face
et il ya plein de choses qui m'a jamais
mais peut-être s'il fait de trouver un
lieu commun en fait c'est ce qu'est ce
qui se joue dans les gestes
je vais vivre des choses qu'au début
j'ai du mal à formuler articulé après
j'essaie d'être une manière des
particuliers et quand on trouve une aire
de désarticuler alors on se dit on voit
d'autres choses d'autres options
ah ah
remove est une sa création 2015 est une
recherche sur le mouvement sur son
vocabulaire des mouvements des fines et
par un but pratique frappé éviter ou
lancer ça fait un sacré des séquences de
mouvements très très très dynamique qui
engage tout le corps ou qui sont souvent
très explosive et l'idée c'est aussi de
susciter une sensation de mouvement
il ya des mouvements quand on les
regarde même si on ne bouge pas soi même
on va sentir car par empathie le
mouvement et j'ai l'impression que ça a
souvent affaire cette lan bâti et
souvent créés lorsque le mouvement est
incomplet ou lorsque le mouvement est
pas totalement achevée à tout juste 29
ans noé soulier est une étoile montante
du paysage chorégraphique